bien pues vamos a decir que aquí tengo a
mi vector posición pm el cual es un
vector columna y es el vector columna am
se me ocurre 21 es este de aquí y bueno
si lo queremos graficar y de hecho
justos lo que quiero que hagamos vamos a
graficar este vector posición así que
voy a decir que este es mi hijo james y
bueno por acá voy a poner a mi eje x va
a ser este de por aquí ok y bueno
asumiendo que esta primera componente es
mi coordenada en x bueno entonces voy a
tener que caminar 2 para cada uno 2 1
hacia arriba y justo por aquí en este
punto va a estar mi vector posición y de
hecho lo podemos representar lo podemos
representar con este símbolo de vector
que estoy poniendo justo por aquí donde
bueno mi cola va a estar en el origen y
mi cabeza va a estar en este punto o
bueno también puedo decir que este punto
solito representa justo mi vector es
decir su posición en el plano cartesiano
y bueno lo que voy a querer hacer en
este vídeo es aplicar una transformación
a este vector posición que tengo aquí y
lo voy a hacer multiplicando a éste
posición por una matriz y el producto de
esta multiplicación me va a dar otro
vector posición así que bueno a qué me
refiero con todo esto
bueno pues voy a tener una matriz de la
transformación de t mayúscula y bueno
pues vamos a decir que esta matriz es la
matriz 2 2
1 - 1 y 2 ok esta matriz que tengo aquí
21 menos 1 y 2 así que bueno que va a
pasar si multiplico aporte pues que te
parece si lo hacemos justo por aquí voy
a multiplicar a t por p y bueno lo
primero que sería muy bueno hacer es
darnos cuenta que esto representa una
operación válida es decir que esto está
bien definido según la multiplicación de
una matriz por un vector así que déjame
ponerlos por aquí y para eso déjenme
atraparlos
ok los voy a copiar y pegar pegamos
primero está que esté ok y después voy a
atrapar copiar y pegar ap que es justo
este de aquí y veamos esto se puede
multiplicar es decir puedo multiplicar
una matriz de dos por dos por un vector
que es un vector columna
o dicho de otra manera una matriz de 2
por 1 pues claro que sigue como sabemos
la multiplicación de una matriz está
bien definida si nosotros nos damos
cuenta que las columnas de la primera
matriz de esta que tengo aquí el número
de columnas es exactamente igual que el
número de filas que tenemos en la
segunda matriz es decir en esta de aquí
y bueno estos muy obvios date cuenta que
ambos son dos y por lo tanto esto nos va
a dar de resultado una matriz de dos por
uno y eso es muy importante recuerda que
nos va a dar de resultado una matriz de
dos por uno y lo que es muy interesante
es que el resultado de esto también nos
va a dar un vector columna o de otra
manera un vector posición es decir que
si nosotros nosotros vamos a este vector
p que tenemos justo aquí y lo
multiplicamos por una matriz de
transformación nos va a dar de resultado
un vector de 2 por 1 el cual también lo
podemos pensar como un vector posición
porque lo podemos graficar justo aquí en
nuestro plano cartesiano o dicho de otra
manera lo que nos está dando esta matriz
de transformación es mandando este punto
que tenemos aquí a otro punto en el
plano dicho de otra manera estamos
a este punto así que es buen momento
para saber que nos va a dar de resultado
y bueno nuestra primera entrada de aquí
la podemos ver como la multiplicación de
la primera fila de esta matriz por bueno
por la única columna que tenemos así que
déjame utilizar un color nuevo y voy a
multiplicar esta fila por esta columna y
eso va a ser igual a 2 por 2 lo cual es
cuatro más uno por uno lo cual es 1 esto
lo podemos ver como cuatro más uno o
dicho de otra manera como 5 y ahora para
la segunda entrada que tenemos aquí
vamos a tener que multiplicar la segunda
fila por la primera y única columna que
tenemos aquí así que menos 1 por 2 es
menos 2 más 2 por 1 lo cual es dos más
dos menos dos más dos bueno pues eso lo
podemos poner como cero esto es
solamente cero así que ahora tenemos la
posición 50 así que vamos a ponerle a
quienes planos tengo 1 2 1 2 3 4 y 5 y
entonces empezamos con este vector
posición p que tenemos justo aquí y
ahora
lo hemos transformado en este otro
vector posición que tengo justo aquí y
es más déjame llamarlo p prima esté aquí
este prima y bueno si lo queremos
representar de la forma tradicional en
que se representa un vector este de aquí
este de aquí es p prima el vector de
prima mientras que este de aquí este de
aquí va a ser nuestro vector p el vector
p de lujo y de hecho dejan ponerle aquí
la comida
este es prima este spin y date cuenta
que pasamos del vector p al vector que
priman utilizando esta matriz de
transformación